grüner knopf fähre kleidung mit einem
neuen siegel will die bundesregierung
die textilbranche gerechte und sicherer
machen
zu wenige lehrer für immer mehr schüler
an deutschlands grundschulen wird sich
der lehrermangel drastisch verschärfen
warnt eine studie von hakenkreuzen und
hitler bildern einer ausstellung in den
niederlanden widmet sich dem design des
dritten reichs und erntet kritik
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und ein
herzliches willkommen zu den heute
nachrichten an meiner seite ist für den
sport norbert lehmann sehr gern eine
schöne und auch von mir
wie erkenne ich als kunde ob kleider
fair und nachhaltig produziert worden
sind
der grüne knopf soll das einfacher
machen
ein gütesiegel das entwicklungsminister
müller die evangelische kirche und
unternehmer heute vorgestellt haben
antrieb dazu war der einsturz der
achtstöckigen textilfabrik reiner plasa
in bangladesch 2013
dabei starben mehr als 1100 menschen
etliche westliche kleidung firmen hatten
dort produzieren lassen
unter menschenunwürdigen bedingungen die
arbeitsbedingungen in der branche global
zu verbessern
das ist ziel des grünen knopfes die
initiative sei gut meinen kritiker die
umsetzung aber noch nicht entlassen wir
verändern mode will heißen verbessern
die produktionsbedingungen von kleidung
entwicklungshilfeminister müller hat
sich ganz schön viel vorgenommen
was er mit dem grünen knopf erreichen
will ein staatliches siegel das ab
sofort ökologisch nachhaltig und sozial
produzierte textilien erkennbar machen
will mir die reifen wohlstands nationen
leben doch ganz stark zu kosten der
menschen und der natur in den
entwicklungsländern
dort wird produziert zu unwirtlichsten
bedingungen das muss sich ändern
die arbeit häufig extrem schlecht
bezahlt außerdem arbeitszeiten bis zu 16
stunden am tag umweltstandards fehlen
oder werden ignoriert
das siegel soll für gekennzeichnete
textilien nun garantieren dass
beispielsweise mindestlohn bezahlt wird
oder auch dass keine kinderarbeit
stattfindet vom staat eingesetzte
unabhängige prüfer wie ihr der tüv
rheinland kontrollieren
insgesamt 46 kriterien müssen einzelne
produkte aber auch das gesamtunternehmen
erfüllen
das siegel kann verbrauchern
orientierung beim nachhaltigen taxi
einkauf bieten denn verbraucher sind
aktuell mit einem dschungel an siegeln
konfrontiert und wünschen sich mehr
orientierung und doch gibt es auch
kritik unter anderem daran dass in der
einführungsphase des siegels nur die
letzten produktionsschritte überprüft
werden nicht aber etwa der baumwollanbau
kritik auch dass das siegel für
unternehmen freiwillig ist die standards
nicht für alle verpflichtend sind um
fabrik einstürze oder aber auch
kinderarbeit grundsätzlich in der
textilproduktion zu minimieren brauchen
wir eine gesetzliche regelung die alle
unternehmen betrifft im moment nicht
durchsetzbar sagt der minister dazu und
setzt darauf dass das freiwillige siegel
angenommen wird 27 unternehmen machen
bislang mit dürfen den grünen knopf an
überprüften textilien anbringen
rund 40 weitere unternehmen haben sich
bereits beworben
das in deutschland lehrer fehlen das ist
bekannt neu ist aber wie groß der mangel
ist vor allem an grundschulen in den
nächsten jahren fehlen mehr als 26.000
kollegen sagt eine studie der
bertelsmann stiftung und die
kultusminister räumen ein dass die lage
ernster ist als erwartet
warum das so ist und was helfen könnte
zeigt ariane gödel kaum auf dieser welt
und schon werden ihnen probleme voraus
gesagt in sechs jahren nämlich wenn sie
in die grundschule kommen
bis dahin wird sich der mangel an
grundschullehrer noch einmal dramatisch
verschärfen so die jüngste studie der
bertelsmann stiftung
die haupterkenntnis unserer analyse ist
der lehrermangel wird sich noch stärker
zu spitzen bis 2025 als von den
kultusministern bislang erwartet die
kultusministerkonferenz geht bislang von
15.300 fehlenden grundschullehrern im
jahr 2025 aus es fehlen 11.000 mehr also
26.300 so die prognose der bertelsmann
stiftung
die bertelsmann forscher stützen sich in
ihrer an
auf die neueste bevölkerung schätzung
des statistischen bundesamtes danach
werden bis 2025 168.000 zusätzliche
erstklässler eingeschult
die bevölkerungsprognosen haben sich
ganz einfach verändert und sie verändern
sich aus zwei gründen
wir rechnen heute mit einer deutlich
höheren geburtenrate als noch vor
wenigen jahren
und gerechnet mit deutlich höheren
wanderung zeiten als noch vor wenigen
jahren auch durch zuwanderung nimmt die
zahl der schüler also zu den
lehrermangel zu bewältigen sei eine
herkulesaufgabe so bertelsmann
allein der ausbau von studien und
referendar plätzen wird nicht reichen
sieben jahre dauert die ausbildung
erstens müssen angehende ruheständler
dafür gewonnen werden länger zu
unterrichten über die pensionsgrenze
hinaus die teilzeitquote unter den
grundschul lehrkräften muss sinken und
drittens brauchen wir auch
quereinsteiger wenn er in die schule
kommt wird das problem lehrermangel
wahrscheinlich noch nicht behoben sein
vor 15 jahren hatte die regierung die
meisterpflicht für viele handwerksberufe
abgeschafft jetzt kommt die reform der
reform für zwölf der 50 berufe sollen
betriebs gründe wieder einen
meisterbrief brauchen fliesenleger etwa
estrichleger oder raumausstatter
darauf haben sich die fraktionen von
union und spd geeinigt ziel ist mehr
qualität durch eine bessere ausbildung
der aufschrei ist immens es sei eine
schande unfassbar und müsse rückgängig
gemacht werden
die wahl eines politikers der
rechtsextremen npd als ortsvorsteher in
hessen
der mann war einstimmig von sieben
anwesenden aus spd cdu und fdp gewählt
worden auch weil offenbar niemand
anderes bereit war dieses ehrenamt zu
übernehmen stefan schlosser berichtet
norbert schiller sco kann die ganze
aufregung nicht verstehen er gehört zu
den ortsbeiratsmitgliedern die den
npd-funktionär zum neuen ortsvorsteher
gewählt haben für die bürger da sein
ansprechbar sein darum ginge es nicht um
politik partei spielt bei uns keine
rolle und er ist absolut nicht in dieser
richtung aufgefallen wäre das passiert
wer also in summe aus außen vor gewesen
andere bewerber für das amt gab es nicht
es ist das thema in altenstadt
ich bin beschämt ich bin entsetzt ich
möchte mich in aller form davon
distanzieren und wenn auch schon kippe
wie viele rührende naivität da
vorgegangen wurde
ja die chance gekriegt das muss ich auch
mal beweisen ob er jetzt npd oder spd
oder cdu es wie er ist nach dieser
demokratisch gewählt worden altenstadt
gehört zu den hochburgen der
verfassungsfeindlichen npd in hessen bei
der letzten kommunalwahl holten die
rechtsextremen hier zehn prozent der
stimmen
jetzt jubeln die rechten ihr mann ist
repräsentant von 2500 einwohnern um ihn
geht es der neue ortsvorsteher ist
gleichzeitig stellvertretender
landesvorsitzender der npd immer wieder
beobachtet vom verfassungsschutz
ich finde diesen ganzen aufschrei
drumherum ziemlich lächerlich und
peinlich weil es ist nur ein
ortsvorsteher posten und wir reden nicht
davon dass das hier ein bürgermeister
posten war oder sonst irgendwelche
landräte und deswegen fand ich das
völlig übertrieben alle anderen parteien
sind entsetzt und drängen den ortsbeirat
die entscheidung zu korrigieren
mittlerweile ist ein entsprechender
antrag zur abwahl auf dem weg zwei
drittel der mitglieder im ortsbeirat
müssen dann zustimmen
in großbritannien geht der machtkampf um
den wechsel weiter bevor prämie johnson
das parlament am abend in eine
mehrwöchige zwangspause schickt will er
die abgeordneten erneut über neuwahlen
abstimmen lassen
allerdings gilt es als äußerst
unwahrscheinlich dass johnson die dafür
nötige zwei drittel mehrheit bekommt
unterdessen ist das vom parlament
initiierte gesetz gegen einen
ungeregelten wechselt in kraft getreten
damit ist es nahezu unmöglich dass
großbritannien die eu am 31 oktober ohne
abkommen verlässt sind die russischen
kommunal und regionalwahlen für die
putin-partei einiges russland nun gut
verlaufen oder nicht die frage lässt
sich gar nicht so leicht beantworten im
land insgesamt wurde sie fast überall
wieder stärkste kraft in moskau aber mit
seinen zwölf millionen einwohnern hat
sie massiv verloren die opposition
jubelt christian seinem berichtet
daria bc die naht es geschafft für die
liberale jabloko-partei zieht sie ein
ins moskauer stadtparlament als einer
der wenigen oppositionskandidaten die
für die wahl zugelassen wurden ihren
sieg sieht sie als signal
das war ein konkreter protest um die
wahlen auf den kopf zu stellen damit
kein kandidat der jetzigen führung
gewinnt hätten die menschen auch einen
stuhl gewählt daria habe profitiert sagt
sie vom wahlaufruf den der bekannte
oppositionsführer alexej nawalny
gestartet hatte taktisch abstimmen
sollten die wähler um den kreml nahen
abgeordnetensitze im parlament
wegzunehmen
davon profitierte vor allem die
kommunistische partei im ganzen land das
können wir sagen hat die taktische wahl
funktioniert das war besser als wir
erwartet haben und zum ersten mal in
moskau gewannen die von der opposition
unterstützten kandidaten insgesamt 20
der 45 stadtratssitze in den meisten
regionen der landesweiten abstimmung
aber setzte sich die kreml partei
einiges russland klar durch das moskauer
ergebnis ein dämpfer für präsident putin
aber hört man ministerpräsident mit vegf
klingt alles nach einem großen erfolg
die partei einiges russland hat ein sehr
gutes überzeugendes ergebnis erzielt das
zeigt das vertrauen unserer bürger die
wochenlangen massenproteste tausende
festnahmen und polizeigewalt haben nicht
dazu geführt dass die wähler in massen
zur wahl gegangen sind
die wahlbeteiligung lag in der
russischen hauptstadt gerade mal bei
21,7 prozent
dorian wütet über den bahamas fast eine
woche liegt diese nachricht inzwischen
zurück doch noch immer lässt sich nicht
genau sagen wie verheerend der hurrikan
war zu groß ist das chaos vor allem auf
den beiden inseln grand bahama und great
abaco mindestens 45 tote soll es dort
gegeben haben aber die trümmerlandschaft
lässt weit schlimmeres befürchten die
meisten betroffenen wollen einfach nur
weg unsere reporterin britta jäger ist
im krisengebiet auf great abaco britta
wie erlebst du die lage vor ort
also ehrlich gesagt ziemlich chaotisch
hier in marsh harbour waren wir den
vergangenen tagen am hafen
beispielsweise und da haben sich recht
tumultartige zustände zu getragen denn
die regierung hat es immer noch nicht
geschafft alle menschen hier aus diesen
krisen gebiet zu evakuieren
und sie sind immer noch dabei die
menschen per boot und per flugzeug
heraus zu bringen und die menschen an
dem hafen die haben dagestanden
stundenlang in der brütenden hitze und
es wurden immer nur mal ein paar
ausgezogen die dann platz gefunden haben
auf den wenigen boten und die leute
waren verzweifelt sie wollten hier aus
diesem kaputten aus diesem chaos aus
diesem kaputten gebiet wollten sie
einfach raus morgen sollen auch deutsche
und niederländische marinesoldaten zum
helfen kommen was ist der plan der
regierung geht es weiter also die
regierung hat jetzt gestern verkündet
dass sie eine strategie entwickeln
wollen wie man hier systematisch nach
leichen sucht da wollen sie jetzt das
komplette gebiet in der 4 ecke aufteilen
und diese vierecke dann systematisch
durchforsten und wenn das passiert ist
und es wird ein langer prozess sein erst
dann können überhaupt die
aufräumarbeiten beginnen denn wir haben
jetzt hier auch in den letzten tagen als
wir hier waren gesehen dass in dieser
hinsicht eigentlich noch überhaupt gar
nichts passiert ist und da beschweren
sich die leute hier natürlich auch ganz
bitter
die regierung hat auch angekündigt dass
sie jetzt für 4000 menschen bald auf der
insel abaco hier jetzt temporäre
unterkünfte errichten will
deshalb möchten sie dann auch dass die
menschen so schnell wie möglich
zurückkehren aber sie werden natürlich
in ein gebiet zurückkehren das noch
vollständig zerstört ist weil das
aufräumen und das aufbauen wird noch
monate dauern
aufführende eindrücke von den bahamas
dankeschön peter jäger und das gespräch
haben wir vor einer stunde aufgezeichnet
ihr flug ist gestrichen heute und morgen
gilt das für zehntausende passagiere von
british airways denn fast alle piloten
streiken zum ersten mal in der
geschichte der fluglinie british airways
stornierte 1700 verbindungen von und
nach london heathrow und gatwick london
city wird aber angeflogen die piloten
wollen mehr gehalt ein
angebot über 11,5 prozent mehr hatten
sie zuletzt abgelegt und jetzt schauen
wir auf ein ganz anderes thema auf eine
gewagte design schau im niederländischen
den bosch es ist die gestaltung des
bösen sagen die ausstellungsmacher und
zeigen rolle und geschichte des designs
im nationalsozialismus nazi ästhetik die
erfolgreich massen von menschen in ihren
bann zog
kritiker befürchten dass so die ns-zeit
verherrlicht wird
die macher versprechen geschichte werde
analysiert und in keiner weise
beschädigt gunnar krüger berichtet darf
man dass das schöne im bösen suchen die
wucht und den trotz ausstellen ein möbel
aus der reichskanzlei design des dritten
reich so umfassend wie noch nie
sonntag kam erster besucher ich fand das
sehr beeindruckend und gehen nun mit
einem kloß im hals nach hause
es zeigt wie verräterisch das böse sein
kann wie man in schöne dinge
verwerfliche den klassikern idee kommt
lotti jahres von der flug sein gute form
unterm hakenkreuz das war metall und
moderne holz und heimat rückwärtsgewandt
und zukunftsweisend kurz widersprüchlich
denn gutes design im sinne der nazis war
schlicht was ihre macht sicherte das zu
zeigen weil lange umstritten in der
stadt den bosch die gleich neben ihrem
design museum 293 ermordeten jüdischen
bürgern gedeckt ich habe beschwerden aus
allen ecken gehört von
widerstandskämpfern verbraucht die
jüdische seite hatte ihre einwände zu
groß die sorge dass rot schwarz weiße
markenbild der nazis könnte bei manchen
besucher noch immer die kraft zur
verfügung haben und ich hoffe sogar dass
neonazis kommen
sie könnten denken hier geht es um
devotionalien vielleicht gefällt ihnen
das sogar
aber dann wird jeder lernen all das
endete im holocaust endete im völkermord
so war auch der judenstern ein design
entwurf am schreibtisch
missbraucht von den nationalsozialisten
für ihre verbrechen eine ausstellung die
polarisiert zu sehen noch bis zum 19
januar in den bosch in den niederlanden
und damit sind wir beim fußball norbert
heute abend in belfast nordirland gegen
deutschland ja unter will und muss das
team von joachim löw nach der pleite
gegen die niederlande gewinnen damit es
nicht zu eng wird in der em
qualifikation aber die starken nordiren
die sind gruppen-erste vier spiele vier
siege breit und angenehm ist der weg zur
em-endrunde jetzt nicht mehr
er führt durch eine region in der nicht
nur aber auch im fussball hart
gearbeitet wird und dann kommt auch noch
das für nordirland passende wetter dazu
nach dem 2 4 gegen die niederlande ist
kein platz mehr für schönreden vor allem
in der abwehrarbeit waren gehörige
defizite zu erkennen
wir waren über 90 minuten die
schlechtere mannschaft haben verdient
verloren dann weiß man schon auch dass
man hier mit aller macht drei punkte
anstreben muss in der abwehrkette ist
kein platz mehr für den zuletzt
schwachen jonathan ta dass ilkay
gündogan krank ist könnte die
nominierung von riesen talent kei herz
zur folge haben joachim löw muss
jedenfalls mehr umbauen als ihm lieb ist
rafael nadal ist zum vierten mal us open
sieger in einem an spannung kaum zu
übertreffenden finale schlug er daniel
medwedew in fünf sätzen und fast fünf
stunden
die totale erschöpfung des siegers ließ
ahnen wie hart in seinem gegner fast
fünf stunden lang gefordert hatte rafael
nadal war gegen daniel medwedew der
glückliche sieger in einem
fünf-satz-match das eigentlich keinen
verlierer verdient gehabt hätte der
23-jährige russe zeigte in seinem ersten
major finale das ihm als einem der
spieler der next generation zu der auch
alexander zverev zelt im professionellen
tennis die zukunft gehört noch aber
scheinen die großen drei nadal federer
und djokovic unantastbar
für den 33-jährigen spanier war es heute
in new york bereits der 19
grand-slam-titel insgesamt eine
enttäuschende wm aber immerhin ein
versöhnlicher abschluss die deutschen
basketballer die haben in china in ihrem
letzten spiel kanada mit 82 zu 76
besiegt und damit die teilnahme an
europäischen olympia
qualifikationsturnier gesichert
in einem mäßigen spiel lag das deutsche
team in weiss nach der pause mit elf
punkten hinten dann kam der beste werfer
dennis schröder zu distanz punkten und
es wurde gezaubert maximilian kleber 83
sekunden vor dem ende zum
vorentscheidenden 78 zu 71 am ende 82 zu
76 für die deutsche auswahl die im juni
nächstes jahr noch die chance zur
olympia-qualifikation hat bei einem
turnier mit sechs teams der sieger fährt
nach tokio das was von mir
das wetter bringt heftigen regen im
osten für teile thüringens und sachsens
gibt es unwetterwarnungen
heute nacht schüttet es noch morgen dann
nur noch im nordosten mehr dazu gleich
von katja roll war das heute journal um
viertel nach elf mit christian sievers
danke für ihr interesse machen sie sich
noch einen schönen montagabend und bis
morgen wenn sie mögen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren endlich ist
der regen auch im osten deutschlands
angekommen das ging jetzt in der nacht
los und dann zog der regen weiter nach
norden
innerhalb von 24 stunden sind da
durchaus 20 bis 55 liter regen pro
quadratmeter zusammen gekommen das
können sie auch 55mm nenner unter den
regenwolken bleibt es heute nacht mit da
sinken die temperaturen auf 14 bis 10
grad sonst gibt's einstellige werte und
am kältesten war es am alpenrand mit nur
zwei grad das heißt dort droht
bodenfrost dort ist es nämlich zum teil
klar und es bildet sich auch mal nebel
wie hier der donau
nordöstlich der elbe aber schüttet
dessen der nacht ergiebig weiter und
doch morgen über tag regnet es noch
länger erst am abend lassen dann die
regenfälle auch in mecklenburg
vorpommern nach
dafür nimmt der wind durch zu das ist
ein starker bis stürmischer wind aus
westlichen richtungen
sonst wechseln sonne und wolken ab und
die nebelfelder an der donau sollten
sich eigentlich alle auflösen platz
morgen unter den regenwolken mit nur 16
17 grad sonst aber werden 18 bis 22 grad
erreicht und dann wird es von tag zu tag
von südwesten und westen immer etwas
wärmer schönen abend noch